[Music]
i was in hawaii when it happened i was
like on a beach
and then uh like luna crashed and i was
like which is literally zero and i was
like oh man and like for a day or two i
just like
um
like like kind of [__] up my vacation
in a way but not because i was like
doing something like i didn't even have
access to my like my wallets not just
like on in the cloud so like
i just wasn't home i couldn't even sell
if i wanted to i couldn't do anything
really um and then i didn't even want to
be doing something i was like i want to
be enjoying this vacation you know tell
me what happened can you tell me like
you had told me you're like luna's kind
of cool and you're you told me like six
or eight weeks ago yeah actually so i
did something cool too in the last few
days you'll see it come out i
i
i went really over the top with a piece
of content i haven't done this since i
did that clubhouse thread that was
extremely over the top but i was like i
kind of find this entertaining and this
might hit and the clubhouse one like
really hit hit like i don't know like 20
million people saw that thing
i did that again with the luna stuff
where i recorded i basically am creating
like a um almost like a john oliver
style
show you know his show last week tonight
or whatever
where he just kind of like dismantles
one topic for like 15 minutes and it's
like but it's peppered with jokes i did
that on the lunar thing so that's going
to come out last day or two but that was
a very fun exercise to try to like so
tell me well actually try to be funny
but the story is i guess for those who
don't know okay so
um
here's the short ver here's the short
version of the story short version of
the story is
you have bitcoin gets big has this like
anonymous creator and it's supposed to
do like one thing really well which is
like basically this like digital gold
and then you have ethereum gets really
big and it's got this guy vitalik he
becomes the next cult hero first it was
satoshi for bitcoin then it becomes
metallic and metallic solves a major
problem with bitcoin which is that he
makes it programmable and ethereum takes
off and ethereum's more programmable
form of money but both bitcoin and
ethereum have like one major problem
which is that they're not very good as
actual currencies right they're called
cryptocurrencies but you don't use them
as a day-to-day currency you don't use
them to go buy stuff and this is for
like a variety of reasons right like
bitcoin if you try to spend it you'll
get taxed as if you just sold a home
every time you do a transaction and then
the merchant doesn't want it because
they're like oh [__] what tomorrow this
is going to go down 20 price like dude
i'm not trying to invest i just need
money to pay for tomorrow's inventory
like i don't want to take this in my
coffee shop and so it's not really you
those aren't really you so basically
there's this idea of creating
stable coins there's a coin that's
always going to be worth one dollar and
like
this is the spoiler it's like
you know you don't want it to not be
worth one dollar which is what happened
with with the tara project but like
um
you know it's supposed to be worth one
dollar so the way that most people did
it the big ones usdc tether those are
the two big ones
they're like it's basically like um like
like a safety deposit box you give them
a real dollar they'll give you a digital
dollar and if you ever want a real
dollar back they're like i promise it's
in the bank vault whenever you need it
come back and redeem it
and um
and those kind of have some controversy
because crypto people don't like it
because it's like
well how do i know you're not lying like
how do i know you didn't just take all
that money in the bank vault and go
spend it or invest it in some risky way
and that's why people think tether did
uh does
and uh and also they're like dude what
if the government just cracks down this
one company like they could just like
they have to operate in some country
yeah like it's centralized
the whole it's yeah it's centralized
this decentralization thing isn't real
so at that point so okay so that's the
pro so the pro argument for this project
that came out that's the project's
called tarot and one of the currencies
called luna so the idea was we need a
decentralized stable coin we need to
decentralize does that mean that one
person invented tara and then another
person invented luna using terrorist
technology no no terror is like the name
of the company terraform labs it's like
a group of people who came together said
we're going to create a stable coin and
then the stable coin one of them like
it's called ust so you think about it
like the us dollar version of tara ust
and so that was their stable coin that's
something that's always supposed to be
one dollar luna is the tote like luna is
the thing that backs it okay so remember
i said like the in the other version
what backs the digital dollar it's a
real dollar in a bank account and the
way that the us dollar used to work was
what backs the us dollar gold and fort
knox right and that was before we got
off the gold standard but the idea is
like what gives this currency any value
is this like backing currency
and so they were backing it with luna
and luna was meant to be this like it's
like two they they basically created two
coins the stable coin and then luna
which goes which can actually go up and
down in price as a stabilizing mechanism
for the stable one so whatever these are
some details they're not super important
to the to what actually happened so but
it was one guy right because i saw like
he's like the founder but like there's a
team right there's a it's a company okay
so it's like a startup right mark
zuckerberg that's this guy doe quan got
it so dokwan who's dokwan he's a pretty
interesting character right because
he basically it's like stanford computer
science
uh graduates he starts working on some
like mesh networking internet thing like
that was his first startup and then he's
like oh no crypto is like the future i'm
gonna create the stablecoin project so
they come out with this idea and there's
basically some people are skeptical
because they've seen this uh
decentralized stable coin this this
uncollateralized decentralized
algorithmic a bunch of buzzwords but
that's how you describe it
stablecoin failed before there was a
project like this called basis cash
maybe five years ago and basis basically
raised like i don't know 80 million
dollars or something like that from like
tier like i don't know andrews horowitz
a bunch of other vcs but they didn't
even launch they were like they were
like oh
like that we don't know if this
algorithmic thing will will hold so they
kind of returned 85 of the money as like
a failed project um
so that was like the last big version of
this that had come out and then tara
comes out and so
tara the the difference was they were
like look this works as long as there's
demand for the stable coin and so they
were like where's the demand come from
and at first this is i guess i said it
was a short versus actually the long
version story but at first he came out
with us with this idea that was like
look we'll use it for e-commerce because
in e-commerce every time there's a
transaction you know there's like a
three percent credit card fee basically
we can do it at one percent if we use
crypto and so it's like for a merchant
that's like you know that's real money
that you get to save if somebody uses
this this at this option and what they
did was they're like yo we'll pass the
savings to the customer and to the
merchant 50 50. and then they like went
and talked to all these e-commerce
companies in korea where they're from
and they got like 27 large e-commerce
companies including the second biggest
one in in korea to use them so like
imagine like the set like not amazon but
like let's say ebay yeah yeah they got
ebay to use it so everyone's like pretty
hyped they're like oh [__] this is
crypto with a real real world use case
finally like real world use case this is
hyped on it i was hyped on it and this
guy because he was on stage he's like
look crypto's full of a bunch of
projects that have no real world use
cases and very low user bases we have
like a real problem that we're solving
and we're gonna and we have real user we
have two million people using our
payments app to do this in korea and i
was like wow awesome i buy it and then
things started to get a little bit where
you invested can you explain you want to
i started i started with 25k and then i
had an opportunity to put in another
200k
as part of like
a bunch of vcs were
buying uh luna like they invested in the
company and they were they got to buy
luna at basically like a 40 discount to
the market rate so at the time was
trading at like almost a hundred dollars
we got to buy in at about just under 40
dollars uh but it was like locked up
like it was gonna be released over the
number of years so you did that i did
that so i was like oh dude i like this
project anyways if i get to buy it 50
under market like hell yeah sign me up
and also like these are all like
tier one like crypto investors like
these
they raised a billion dollars right from
it from from investors so it wasn't like
some random project it was like oh well
these guys are smart they're doing it
all right like that's that validates my
my belief okay i'm gonna go ahead and do
this
and for a while it looked like a genius
move because luna was trading at i don't
know it hit like 116 dollars it was like
one of the best performers last year
basically how much were you up by in
about a year and a half luna went from
under a dollar to 116 dollars i did like
100 x in one year i was in at like the
kind of like the 30 35 price point
overall
uh 40
of 30 or 30.
no no my my price point my actual price
point was like 35 dollars blended so
then you were you went i was up three
like 750 yeah exactly my 250 was like
750 grand i was like oh great yeah he's
doing well and like this was just the
start it was like it was growing really
fast like not just the price but like
the number of people buying the stable
coin was going up like it went like i
think the the the stable coin had like i
don't know 18 billion dollars of tvl or
something like that so it had gotten
pretty big
but they had i i kind of noticed i was
like wait they don't talk about the
e-commerce thing ever anymore and that's
because
kind of like didn't work like they
basically
it was like working slowly i think like
uh merchants like kind of cared but not
enough consumers didn't really change
their behavior so it wasn't like a sexy
growth story i don't think it was
working they just stopped talking about
it and they started talking about like
um
so what they did was they were like all
right no instead we'll serve the crypto
community itself with a savings rate so
a savings account so basically there was
a savings account on on the network that
was like if you deposit your stable coin
here you get paid 20 interest
on your stable stable coin which is like
kind of amazing right because like if i
take my dollars i go to bank of america
i get yeah but that sounds like some
ponzi scheme [__] it sounds like it
right but it's not i'll tell you why so
it was like
bank of america gives you 0.02 percent
this is giving you 20
and
and so a lot of critics said exactly you
said which is oh this is a ponzi
and i will argue it is not a ponzi it
was even better than a ponzi yes
so
like one up from a ponzi okay so a ponzi
[__] stealing basically so ponzi is
customer a gives you money you use that
money to pay out customer b then
customer b gives you money because they
have faith in it you use that money to
pay out c and d so you're taking one
customer's money you're paying out the
other this is even better they just
created a currency out of thin air
printed like a billion of it
then
and then they just gave it away right
like and like the market believes it
high value so have you seen on uh what's
that where they have patty just paddy's
dollars on yeah paddy's bucks all of a
sudden
it's always sunny yeah that's exactly
what happened they just created their
own currency and just collected the
dollars in a way that's what all
currencies are right the us doll every
country does this they create their own
currency and you if you believe is
valuable then it becomes valuable if you
if you cease believing it's valuable
then it devalues and we see this in
different countries and that's what
happened here for a while people
believed it was valuable and they kept
investing in it
um and two things happened one was
everybody knew that this 20 savings rate
is not sustainable because
what they were okay the the reality the
joke that was my joke version of
description the reality was when they
raised a billion dollars from investors
they basically were like look this
savings rate is really good customer
acquisitions it's a marketing budget
just like uber subsidizes your rides
like why was an uber ride back when we
all started using uber like 12
when a taxi would have been 28 it's like
because vcs were basically giving money
and they were losing money on the rides
and that's what that's what terra was
doing they were losing money on this
savings rate but they were getting a
whole bunch of new customers so like
they got like four million people almost
to create wallets on the network so it
was like
they were buying user acquisition now
you could argue that was either dumb or
not done but it was definitely
unsustainable and everybody kind of
anybody smart knew that that's
unsustainable but it's like hey look i
get rewarded for being early here i'm
gonna get this subsidized earnings
savings rate and that'll go away as this
gets more popular but like cool that's
my benefit for being early that's how
almost every crypto project works
and um it's almost how many many
startups work as well investors
subsidize the usage of your free product
until it's big enough where they'll
start to charge or raise prices
to and then to get to the kind of like
get to the crash i care i care about
your take on like what happened to you
but to get to the crash what happened to
get to the crash okay so all along the
way people are like hey uh algorithm is
stable coins they only work when demand
keeps going up
once demand starts to fall this thing
will free fall so yeah you have demand
right now that's why everything looks
good but once this starts to fall it'll
create a death spiral meaning
once people stop wanting usc luna's
price will go down people will start
once luna's price starts going down
people start selling luna and uh
basically it's this like interplay
between
if
if ust either started to d-peg meaning
instead of being worth a dollar it was
worth 95 cents people will not want it
they'll lose confidence in the in the
stable coin and as they lose confidence
they'll they'll sell which will create
more supply of luna which will cross the
price of luna to go down and then that
will cause even less confidence in the
whole project and it'll just death
spiral that was this is the belief and
all along this guy dokwan who started
off like you know seeming like this
smart kind of want to change the world
kind of guy he'd become like kind of an
egomaniac and it was part of his persona
like he was like a donald trump or elon
musk style guy where
if you were if you disagreed with him he
didn't just say you know like i agree
let's agree to disagree like he was like
i will [__] on you i will call you
stupid and poor and like i will make fun
of you is that literally what he said
yeah he would call everybody stupid poor
and he would basically oh my god say
you're all they're all fudsters just
spreading fud which is fear uncertainty
and doubt you know and look they've been
wrong all the way so far they're going
to keep being wrong and this is exactly
what elon did about people who were
shorting his stock he was like oh it's
going to be the short burn of the
century you guys are going to look so
stupid and uh and and you know people
are betting against them people are
betting for him so anyways yeah but he
this guy forgot like the thing to make
this work is you have to be right
exactly and he was right for a while
until and and by the way it's really
funny there's one twitter account that
wasn't just saying hey this ain't gonna
work he's like specifically laid out
a like 15 step plan of like hey look i
did the math if somebody was motivated
and had a billion dollars they could
destroy tarot which is currently worth
40 billion dollars so they could if you
put up if you had a billion dollars of
cell pressure i think you could crack
the whole tara project uh it would have
to be like a smart focused person who
would have to time it right so and
that's ex and basically he he he
retweeted that was like this is like
famous last word so he goes
man this is the most
r word uh thing i've ever read on
twitter
um
well billionaires if you wait he said
[__] yeah
uh really
yeah what a dumb idiot why would he do
that
would you call him a dumb idiot
well like but like why would you dumb
idiot would do such name calling
how can you how could you speak like
that when you're like this like uh like
a ceo of like a that's just like donald
trump called mexicans rapists and stuff
dude this is like crazy like people are
crazy they do crazy [__] and then
they're basically their fans in his case
we call lunatics we're like yeah and
then like they thought that was cool
well i don't know if they thought that
specific wording was cool but in general
his character i mean he renamed himself
stable quan he became a billionaire he
like got a million twitter followers
because he became a cult of personality
similar to god what an idiot though so
anyways he tweets and he's really an
idiot because he go he said this is the
most awkward thing i've read on on
twitter all week um
and he goes
billionaires who follow me go like um
please go ahead and try this
um and like sure enough like two weeks
later or a week later it's like and try
it they did so basically somebody or
some group it's not confirmed who it is
uh it's not confirmed also that there's
a coordinated attack but it does seem
like it
people started uh somebody started
dumping like a billion dollars worth of
the stable coin which caused the peg to
go down right when you have that much
cell pressure it won't stay worth a
dollar it still slipped to 92 cents and
then it's and then on on top of that
they were also dumping bitcoin which was
the reserve collateral that these guys
are holding so bitcoin's price starts to
go down ust starts to break peg people
start to panic a little bit and they
also started withdrawing from so they
did three things they took it out of
anchor the savings protocol so you saw a
billion dollars worth or whatever like
withdrawals then you saw them sell it
then you saw bitcoin price tanking and
all of a sudden people started getting a
little worried about oh [__] is
something bad happening to tara let me
just go ahead and sell so more people
start to sell and so you see like three
four five billion dollars of sales
happening in a very short period of time
and this also
coincidentally or very planned happened
right when they were doing like a kind
of like imagine you're like oh i'm just
i'm moving houses right now i was like
oh man the doors are open huh
because you're the moving trucks outside
so the doors are open that's basically
what happened they were moving all the
liquidity from the liquidity pool from
one to another and so there wasn't much
there was less shock absorbers than than
you would expect when they started to
sell it went from 100 over 100 to what
what's it at now less than a penny like
fractions of what yeah okay so how much
value was wiped out 40 something billion
dollars 48 billion that is crazy that is
the stable coin went from selling so
that's luna tara the stable coin the ust
was selling at you know it's a dollar
supposed to always be a dollar it goes
92 cents 85 cents so i'm i'm on the
beach in hawaii and i'm just getting
texts from ben yo tara's de-pegging um
and it's like and then it goes down to
70 cents then it shoots back up to 90
giving false hope for a second and then
it plunges to 65 60 50 and i think it's
currently trading i don't know 15 cents
to the dollar so you're you're you're
out 250.
i'm about two yeah 225 something like
that how does that feel
i mean it feels shitty of course right
like you know what did your wife say
wait when you're sitting in hold on she
doesn't really care to know nor does she
like want to know the details
i told her
well from all of crypto i was like we
lost several million million dollars in
the last like three months because
crypto has just been selling off like
crazy
and she's like okay so like i shouldn't
buy this bag or i should i was like i
think it's a shouldn't right now let's
go ahead and hold off on that i was like
that's the level of conversation we've
had uh about the whole thing like she's
not she's she stresses about micro stuff
like if we have like a late fee or a
parking ticket she'll freak out
but on the big thing she's like very
chill she's like but how do you feel
about that now now that you've lost
you said something let's just say three
million dollars like
i guess a couple feelings the first was
i'm not surprised like we went in pretty
eyes wide open which was this is a
risk-reward type bet and you don't just
say that you have to like actually know
what is the risk and the risk was always
nobody's ever made an algorithm stable
coin work and by the way the spoil one
spoiler uh this guy doe quan turns out
he was also the anonymous co-founder of
basis
that got leaked as well so it's like
dude you know
fool us all once you know
shame on you fools twice what the hell
is wrong with you that's my take on it
did he did he tweet out like i'm i'm
sorry i'm a dick or like
he's like look we didn't mean for this
to happen obviously like i have no
because some people are like dude did
you
did you benefit from this in some way
like because that happens at crypto
people like raise much money do much
stuff and then like run away with the
money his claim is no we didn't like we
lost more than anyone on this whole
thing uh i feel really bad that this
happened and he's kind of just like you
know tail between his legs a little bit
and he's sulking and he's quieter he's
much quieter now while everybody's like
dancing on his grave deservedly so
because he was cocky as hell right so
like that's what's going on with him
with me it's sort of like all right lost
this money that's not good obviously but
like you know
it doesn't feel good it's sort of
jarring like
i've had startup investments go south
but it kind of happens over a longer
period of time this is like you wake up
on tuesday and like one of your best
performing investments has gone to zero
in 24 hours it's quite jarring to watch
the price drop like a knife
um and be pretty helpless like there's
nothing you could really do about it
partially because my lunar tokens were
locked up and partially because i was
away from my computer uh you know so you
know whatever but you're you're not i
would like i mean i would lose sleep
over that i would be like
almost almost
not not quite scarred but like a little
bit like it would almost be a it would
be close to where i would describe it as
traumatic
yeah it's not that um
for me and again i think it's because
i i mean i write down whenever i do an
investment here's my
here's why i think there's a good
investment and here's what could go
wrong and then what could go wrong was
exactly this which is like
people think that there could be if if
there was a bank run
that this would debt spiral i see no
reason that this wouldn't despise if
there's a bank run i don't know what
would cause a bank run but it's possible
and it's like oh what would cause a bank
run was like either a motivated player
created panic at a time when the project
was vulnerable because all the all
markets stock markets crypto markets are
all down and they were moving the
liquidity right so it's like well the
risk kind of played out like that's okay
like it's like you know it's like i've
had pocket aces get cracked before and i
i wouldn't even call luna pocket aces
it's like i had a flush draw that got
beat okay you know like to use poker
terms i got a flush i got beat like
that's what happens even if i was a even
if i had a 60 chance of winning okay i
got my money in good but like it wasn't
my life savings now there's a lot of
people who lost a lot more money on this
because they put in a lot of money so to
me there's also like a post-mortem of
like okay there's some rules like you
you don't put more than you know 15 in
any one project because all of them have
these like black swan risks and so you
never want to be that vulnerable to any
one thing
is the majority of your net worth in
crypto right now
uh it was not until like
everything cutting yeah
not not including private like not
including private businesses no of the
liquid stuff no it's a little less than
half now it's a little more than half
before so you know but like the stock
market also hasn't done great i don't
know i haven't really dude i've lost so
much i don't log into my thing anymore i
i just i don't even look at it yeah for
me i'm not going to do it i'm not going
to go trade right now so you know for
mental health purposes i don't go
calculate my net worth when it's when
it's so far down
you know there is a good forcing
function i'm like all right great let me
make sure i'm earning money i'm working
hard right like it's very easy when when
like over the last year a year and a
half let's say since the kind of covid
uh you know money printing system i mean
the whole 10 years has been a bull run
or whatever but like the last year and a
half like [__] just inflated like crazy
so it was like uh man do i even need to
work like
i just look up every day and i made a
whole year's salary in a day like you
know
it's kind of demotivating to work and
then this is highly motivating to work
when you start losing a year's salary
per day you know like that starts to uh
you know like add up and so yeah i don't
know like that's i guess my full
reaction to it me too that's exactly
mine as well it's like you just just
make more money yeah
[Music]
you